[موسيقى]
هذه المقاتله انتجتها شركه جنرال ديناميكس
كطائره حربيه اسرع من الصوت ومتعدده
المهام للمسافات المتوسطه دخلت هذه
الطائره الخدمه في عام
1967 صنعت منها طرازات مختلفه لمهام
الاعتراض وكذلك للقذف الاستاتيكي
والاستراتيجي او حتى للاستطلاع تميزت
باجنحتها التي ترتد الى الخلف عند اخذ
وضعيه القتال او الهجوم كما كانت تحمل
الاسلحه بداخلها او على منصات خارجيه
[موسيقى]
يمكن تقسيم مشاركه هذه المقاتله في حرب
فيتنام الى مرحلتين الاولى في عام
1968 لكنها سحبت بعد اشهر قليله عقب سقوط
ثلاث مقاتلات منها نتيجه اعطال فنيه اما
الثانيه فكانت بين عامي 1972 و 1973 بعد
اصلاح هذه الاعطال بل وتحديثها حيث شاركت
في عمليات القصف الاستراتيجي والتكتيكي
[موسيقى]
هذه الاهداف تضمنت منزل الزعيم الليبي
معمر القذافي وقتلت فيها ابنته ردا على
سقوط طائره بان امريكان فوق لوكيربي كما
شاركت طائره الاف مئه 1111 في حرب الخليج
الاولى بل واستخدمت بكثافه في شن ضربات
بالاسلحه الذكيه حيث اطلقت ما يقارب من
60% من الاسلحه الموجهه بالليزر في الحرب